Thank you.
So when my husband Scott and I went to Ethiopia, to adopt a baby,
we left a week early in order so that we could travel around and see the land
from which we were pulling up our son's roots
in order to plant them halfway around the globe. And this week was wondrous,
and it was transformative but it was also very hard. And was hard not
just because of the lack of hot water and
other amenities, but I was terrifically anxious. I had been anxious
for weeks. Because we had recently had a friend go to Russia to adopt a baby and come
back empty handed,
and I was so scared that after all that we had been through, that the rug was
going to be pulled out from under us and we were not going to be going home with this baby after all.
And I had other worries, which were not as important but still.
Another friend of mine had called me, before we left,
and she said to me "Just prepare yourself because the
other families in your adoption travel group are probably going to
be super
Christian.
And I wasn't sure what super Christian meant exactly. But I imagined
that it probably meant like not believing in evolution and not liking Ozzy
Ozzy
Osborne, or Jewish
people or something. And I was
desperately afraid
that, that during this, what was probably going to be the most important week of my life, I was going to
be with these people who were going to judge me.
So I plan my wardrobe and my demeanor very carefully and I decided that
I was going to be somebody respectable. I was not going to be somebody with a naked woman tattooed on
my arm and a history to go with it.
So I vowed to to cover my tattoos and not to swear like
Courtney Love like I usually do. And to be relentlessly upbeat.
Like I imagine churchie people to be.
And what I thought about them was that they
were going to have really bad haircuts,
and
And that they were going to be very friendly, but that they were going to like secretly hate gay people.
And I vowed that I was going to grit my teeth and make these people like me.
So when we got to the capital city of Addis Ababba and I met the other
eight families in our travel group, who we were going to be living with in this big guesthouse for
the next week, I discovered very quickly that my friend had been both wrong and right.
They weren't all super Christian. There was a handful of arty liberal types, and
there were a whole bunch of shiny cheeked Christians from the heartland, some of whom
had never left Wisconsin a day in their life before they had got on this plane to Africa.
And how we spent the next couple of days was we did our final paperwork and we pace
the living room jet lagged late into the night and we shared
meals. So one morning at breakfast I reached over for the pancakes
and my sleeves rolled up and showed my tattoos and one of the Wisconsin
moms was sitting next to me, and she was like "Ooooh!"
And
I was like, OK here we
go. And she said "Ooooh that is so pretty".
and I was surprised. And I had
this thought that like, maybe she
was different, than what I thought? And then I thought,
Oh, I get it, these people are
very tricky.
And I'm going to watch out for that.
So this
is basically how we spent the final few days of what for all of us had
been a very long wait to meet our children. And then finally one morning,
we all got into a bus, and we went to this three story orphanage.
stucco orphanage behind a tall gate. And we left our shoes at the door. And
we walked in and we waited, in this big downstairs living room.
And I sat next to Scott, and I held his hand and I just sat
absolutely still. And I thought that if I let one tear fall down my face that I was
going collapse into a pile on the floor
and never get up again. And then they started calling people's names.
And one by one each family went up the stairs. And when they came back down again,
they had their child in their arms. And they were just holding these babies,
like they were made of glass, and everyone's face was radiating so much
hope and joy and relief
And there we were watching these families be
born. And we were the very last name called. And we went up
the stairs we followed the social worker into this big room, that was lined
with wooden multi-colored cribs and there were blankets strewn all over the floor in
these adorable babies rolling
around and playing with toys, and in the very middle of the room in this little chair,
sat my son. ?Taricoo?. I recognized him
immediately from the pictures, he has this very wide distinctive forehead
and, electric chocolate eyes
And one of the nannies picked him up,
and she handed him to me. And
this meltdown. That I had felt on the verge of for months, just
dissolved into this primeval calm, the minute I had my baby in my
arms. And Scott on the other hand...
Big tough Scott.
My former United States Marine husband, was standing next
to me, weeping.
And ?Taricoo? reached his perfect little hand over and wiped a tear
off his father's face
face.
And we played with the abies for the rest of that day in the orphanage but we were required to leave them
there that night. So I put Taricoo down in his crib, and the crib had
a photograph of us taped to the inside that we had been allowed
to send at Christmas. And I had
this overwhelming urge to take him, and run for the door,
and never look back.
Because I was so sure that this miracle that
was being dangled in front of us was a cruel joke and it was going to be taken away from us at
any minute. But I didn't. I did not kidnap him.
We left. And the next morning,
we all boarded a bus and took a four hour drive to the southern
region of Ethiopia, to have our entrustment ceremony.
And what an entrustment ceremony is, is it's a chance to
meet any living family members of your child, or for some of the children
to meet the people who had found them and brought them to the steps of the orphanage.
So we went. And when we arrived, I first saw
my son's birth mother, through a
window in the small room where our meeting was going to take place, she was craning her
head around to get a look at us. And we walked in and she ran over and gave us
this big warm hug.
And I was surprised that she was so tiny. She was just a teenage, really.
She had these delicate
bird bones. And she wore her hair very neatly braided under a
red kerchief. And she smelled really nice. She smelled like, like
clothes. And we sat in these three chairs
facing each other and a man translated, slowly,
and her answers to our questions were mostly very quiet and short,
but she lit up a few times. Like she lit up when she told me about
?Taricoo? as a baby, and she said "?Taricoo? means his-story
and I named him this, because he already
has so much history, for such a little boy"
boy.
And the interview, it was way too quick,
but what I took away from it was how kind and how pretty
and how fiery she had seemed. And how even though she had been
unable to care for him she had fought so hard and traveled so far
to save his life.
And when all of the meetings were over we met in a yellow room that
said entrustment ceremony on the wall in English and ?Amharic?
and the birth and the finding families began, and they said a prayer.
And ?Taricoo's? birth mother lit a candle,
and it lit up her beautiful face.
and she handed it to me. And I took it.
And then all the adoptive families said a prayer of gratitude.
And in that moment, I really felt like I was a part of this ancient
and sacred contract, that women have been making with each other since
forever, which is that we take care of each
other. And when need be, we take care of each other's children.
And when it was over she gave us one last hug and she ducked out the door and out of our lives.
In the next morning, finally, finally
we went and we got our children.
And we took them and we bundle them into the carriers and we went to the embassy to do our
final paperwork. And so Scott and I were standing there at the embassy at this window and
it looked like a bank teller. And there was this bulletproof glass and behind the
bulletproof glass was a
man with bloodshot eyes and an unreadable expression and he studied
our paperwork for a long time. And then he
leaned in and he said, through that little hole in the bulletproof glass,
he said "You're not eligible to adopt this baby.
You're only eligible to adopt a baby up to four months old and this baby
is eleven months old."
And he held the paper up to the glass and I
saw where the mistake had been made. And I
said "No, oh no no no no no no no no that's a typo.
And we are eligible to adopt a baby up to four years old. Up
to four years old."
And he said "No, I'm sorry."
And he stood up and he left. And
I waited there for a while holding my sleeping baby on my chest and I was sure
that he was going to return in any minute like "Ugh,
sorry. Our mistake. Beautiful baby. Good luck."
But he didn't. He did not come back and eventually I just started, I started
wandering the room like somebody in shock, just asking anyone who would listen
to me like "What happened to that guy? Where did that
guy go?" And,
we finally went to the waiting room, where all the other families were done. They had gotten
through without a hitch, they had their diaper bags packed, plane tickets for the next day, papers signed,
ready to go.
And I told the social worker what had happened and then she left,
without any explanation about where she was going or when she was coming back.
And at this point I just started sobbing and babbling
incomprehensibly
And all of the families closed ranks
around us. And they reassured us
us, in ways that only they could have, in the entire
world, at that moment. And they were done. They could have
left
at any time. And they didn't. They stayed with us.
They dug their heels in and our babies played together on these filthy floors with
nothing to do. For three hours. And
during that time. I sought about how lonely.
Scott and I had felt at home for the last couple of years while we had been going through this adoption
process because it seemed like every other day, some otherwise
well meaning friend of ours would make some totally boneheaded comment like "Oh I'm
sure that after you
guys adopt you're going to be able to get pregnant with a kid of your own." Or,
I even had one former friend who told me,
who told me that before she was going to schedule
to schedule a playdate, she would need to see documentation of my kids
HIV status.
status.
And I looked around at the families and I thought I have more in common with each one of
these people than I do with most of my friends at home combined.
combined.
And a few hours later, the social worker came back.
And she walked up to me, and she handed me our paperwork.
And she said "It's all taken care of"
Very nonchalantly. She said "I don't know what you are so worried
about"
And we
all stood, together, and went back to the bus.
But I didn't believe it, I didn't believe it was true, I didn't believe he was truly ours,
Until I was feeding him his bottle,
when the plane left the ground. And I looked around
at the sleeping babies on that plane. And I thought
"These people that I judged so harshly because I was so sure that they were going
to judge me,
they're not our friends, they're our
family, now". And they still are.
Thank you.
Thank.